[Music]
it's a fascinating time to be a person
it really is so interesting right now
it's a good time
oh yeah it's a great time also a rough
time shooters and that stuff that's fun
he's out part especially in charge to
earn a Thousand Oaks house a safe ass
place yeah how is the number reign a
former Marine I'm not a dude it was in
the Las Vegas shooting as a survivor was
a survivor in the Thousand Oaks shooting
you know the [ __ ] odds about same
here men seyn think about the odds of
that that's why I think about the up
well I think there was so who's in the
Vegas shooting who survived that who's
that this one that died right I think so
either way it's dark [ __ ] they don't
have no idea what his motive or anything
right the cops had investigated him they
investigated him fairly recently because
they thought he was unstable or
something I think his mom called the
cops like some somebody called the cops
and they investigated him talk to him
that's always tough if your f guys like
what you want to do arrest them for
being [ __ ] weird like you know it's
like what can we do for everyone that
does this [ __ ] trail the guy not
thousand that don't you know I mean you
got to figure out what the [ __ ] is it
that allows people to decide hit that
switch like I don't know if they
understand that like what's the
psychological motivation of that but
it's gotta be a sign that there's
something wrong with our culture if it's
popping up so often it's gotta be a sign
that something's there's something wrong
in the obviously they always chalk up to
mental health and all right yeah he's
you know many people have mental health
issues and yeah we're gonna blow people
up or shuli different kinds of mental
health issues but there's also just bad
people yeah but sometimes you got chalk
it up to that - that's true - but you
know a lot of bad people like a giant
number I've had horrible things happen
yeah that's where it gets weird because
it's like okay what made this guy become
who he is and it's you definitely should
you definitely should arrest someone who
does evil [ __ ] right but what makes a
person get to a point where they can do
evil [ __ ] there's a whole series of
events
we take place including abuse physical
abuse may be sexual abuse and sometimes
there's not sometimes you should get a
bad apple like with Jeffrey Dahmer it's
like his pants like yeah I mean you
definitely get hit some weird [ __ ] with
his mom but still you know some people
were born they have problems with their
liver yeah some people are going to have
problems with their brain that's just a
fact we know that there's problems with
the eyesight there's problems with you
know people people are going deaf yep
there's errors in the human body
sometimes you don't think that someone
could be born just completely squirrelly
wired wrong of course they can socio
that makes sense I'm not a doctor
obviously a [ __ ] [ __ ] but I bet a
doctor would agree that when you're
dealing with mental health issues you're
probably dealing with this giant
spectrum of them what if there's
something we could check so that like
when their baby could check in a song
idea that's called eugenics but in there
like this he's gonna be a bad kid do we
just call you awful he's gonna be about
why how many people hast on the symmetry
of your face but how many people want to
be a better person and they don't ever
get it together and how many people are
lacking like some sort of coaching or
lacking some inspiration inspiration
positive people in their life and then
their life spirals further and further
downhill how many people are on the
border a majority writing yes cuz I
think people change and I think people
improve as they grow older and as they
become wiser and they have more
experiences but also if you if you look
at the mass shooters a lot of them are
quote unquote losers they live in the
parents basement that only thing going
on you look like [ __ ]
use them they're always white and they
toys white low energy always white low
energy some low energy this guy didn't
seem low energy you know the Nazis made
propaganda films basically they made
people believe that mentally deranged
people were out on the streets attacking
and killing people and then a propaganda
film so that they would okay killing
someone who was you know mentally
deranged yeah you always have to be a
careful of people trying to label
someone as someone that you don't have
to consider
human someone who you could disregard
that's what they do with the Jews right
it's like the rats are stealing from us
they're monsters that's what they do it
people have done that throughout history
to other people there's like a
scientific term for it I don't remember
what it is like geniux Allenwood it's a
scientific term for people that demonize
other groups of people and they're the
way they look at propagandists no no the
way you look at people like this is a
person and you looked at the enemy you
would look at them like a subhuman
there's it's like there's a
psychological it is definitely racist
yeah there's like a trait that people
like there's like a pattern that people
commonly fall into with that comment and
the enemy we're all stupid in it we are
stupid but dehumanizing the enemy Cal
it's a natural thing that people do just
[ __ ] everyone does it it's so weird
and it's how people can do gang warfare
it's how people can do tribal warfare
it's how people can do into continental
what were you had your boy what's the
name of the English cat the Hypnotizer
Damon Aaron Brown Karen Brown have you
seen his thing on Netflix no it's
[ __ ] sick and so I'm not it's no
spoiler but so he took a guy like he
took a ton of people took a guy who
lives in Florida who's in construction
and it was super kind of racist towards
immigrants like Mexicans and Hispanics
and he sat him down - he thought he's
the perfect one what